joe biden rolls out his vaccine mandate
democrats struggle for answers after the
virginia election nightmare and the
prosecution's case against kyle
rittenhouse simply does not exist i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't like big tech and the
government spying on you visit
expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first let me just tell
you i really own only one type of
t-shirt it is t-shirts from cut's
clothing and the reason is they are
super comfortable and they fit you
fantastically well and they are
incredibly durable like you don't tend
to think a lot about the t-shirts that
you buy because you just kind of go over
to whatever store there is and then buy
the 10 t-shirt the thing is that thing's
a piece of crap you really should get a
really nice t-shirt from cuts clothing
and they don't just do t-shirts in 2016
cuts founder stephen barely felt boxed
in by his wardrobe he hated having to
compromise between style and comfort so
he decided to do something about it and
started with reinventing the humble
plain tee and the result is a t that gq
calls the only shirt worth wearing it's
stylish enough for the boardroom or the
street comfortable enough for work out
to the gym or nights out at the club
it's just that good cuts has now just
released their new always-on joggers
designed to never take a day off even
when you do whether you're commuting to
the office or out on a date cuts joggers
offer comfort that never quits and style
that never disappoints for a wardrobe as
ambitious as you are it's been seen on
some of the world's most elite athletes
by the way people like patrick mahomes
and damian lillard and tim tebow and
bryce harper just to name a few as i say
i throw out all my other t-shirts i only
wear cuts it's not just a lifestyle it's
not just clothing it's work leisure
apparel for the sport of business get 15
off your first order at
cutsclothing.com that is
cutsclothing.com for 15 off your first
order cutsclothing.com ben well we have
a lot of news and a lot of different
areas to get to today why don't we begin
with the kyle rittenhouse trial which
has finally opened this of course is the
trial of the 17 year old at least he was
17 year old at the time
young man who was in kenosha wisconsin
he was there to
help with medical care for people on the
ground and also to prevent rioters from
burning down businesses and burning cars
and such and the entire situation ended
with three people shot and two people
dead kyle rittenhouse has been charged
now with murder there's one problem
there's no case against calvary in house
and there really is no case at all
against kyle written house they brought
up a sort of minor gun charge that one
is is a little more controversial but
the murder case just it never existed
and the fact that this was ever brought
to trial just demonstrates how political
our judicial system sometimes is it
demonstrates that if a prosecutor gets
it in their head that they must
prosecute somebody regardless of the
facts on the ground they will do so even
when the case just simply does not exist
and we know that the case against
written house doesn't exist because the
prosecution yesterday brought forth a
bunch of witnesses and they all
promptly testified to rittenhouse's
self-defense case and so written house's
argument is that he shot the people who
were threatening him in self-defense and
the prosecution really really struggled
because it turns out that we knew from
the very first day right as soon as the
video footage emerged we knew exactly
what was going on in the written house
case and it was that he had shot people
in self-defense so for example
this entire incident the timeline of the
kyle rittenhouse incident started when
rittenhouse essentially was chased down
the street by some people who are
threatening him
and a gunshot was fired in the air he
turned around and there was a guy who's
lunging for him and so he shot the guy
here's video this is courtesy of abc
news this is video from that night this
is the first shooting
a man who police identified as
rittenhouse runs across the parking lot
of an auto service shop followed by a
shirtless man who was later identified
as joseph rosenbaum
moments later shots ring out
okay now you can stop it right there you
heard a shot before the narrator says
moments later shots ring out
okay well
that first shot was actually not written
house that was somebody who's chasing
him firing a shot into the air written
house is running away has no idea where
the shot's coming from then it turns out
that rosenbaum who it also turns out was
a career criminal is chasing him down
and is lunging for his gun
okay so that is shooting number one
okay so now we move on to shooting
number two ridden house is now being
chased down the street by a bunch of
nerd duels and um and they physically
assault him you know one person comes at
him with a gun he shoots that guy in the
arm another person tries to hit him in
the face with a skateboard he shoots him
and kills him right here is that video
again this is all on video guys
he falls down
you can see he raises the gun there's
somebody trying to hit him with the
skateboard
he shoots he shoots the guy
and then there's a guy who approaches
him he has a pistol in his hand right
the guy approaching him has a pistol in
his hand
hey so all of that is on video right
uncontroverted it's on video
pretty clearly and obviously a case of
self-defense the prosecution is trying
to argue that rittenhouse started the
fight the written house essentially
insulted a guy or tried to initiate
conflict with rosenbaum who's originally
chasing him and the big problem is that
it's pretty clear that's not what
happened and there's fbi infrared video
so it turns out the fbi has eyes on
nearly everything happening in the
united states apparently we never saw
this video until now
and you can see from the video exactly
how this went down
so you have person of interest one and
person of interest two
and you see that they're having some
sort of conversation between the cars
then person of interest two starts
running away being chased by person of
interest one
so what the prosecution is attempting to
claim is that person of interest one
who's rosenbaum was confronted
by written house but that's not what the
testimony of the prosecution's own
witnesses said
they said that
it's precisely the opposite so there's a
witness named ryan belch and he was
again he was called by the prosecution
this guy was not called by the defense
and ryan belch says in open testimony
that rosenbaum had said earlier that if
he caught ridden house alone he would
kill him
okay that's not the prosecutors called
this guy this is their case the
prosecutors here we go
when i turned around
rosenbaum was right there in front of my
face
yelling and screaming
and
i would say dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and he
goes you know what if i catch any of you
guys alone tonight i'm gonna kill you
and he said that to you correct
did he say that to the defendant as well
the defendant was there
so yes
that's the prosecutor's witness
whoops
that's not good
now again this is all undercut the
entire prosecution case here was
undercut by all the footage from the
evening of in fact the prosecutors tried
to bar testimony and bar bar actual
video of written house talking before
any of this happened because there's
video from written house earlier in the
night talking about why he was there in
kenosha wisconsin in the first place
this does not sound like a guy who went
out to shoot some people in the middle
of a riot
so people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is to also help
people if there's somebody hurt i'm
running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself obviously
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a person in
the crowd
so you had non-lethal but you didn't
respond we don't have non-lethal
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes we are now if i can ask can you guys
step back medical ems right here
okay so then the prosecution and then
goes in this video he's trying to help
one of the writers
then the uh the prosecution tries to
bring a second witness there's a guy
named richie mcginnis who's a reporter
for the daily caller who you can see in
the original video who is following
after rittenhouse and uh and rosenbaum
as they are running down the street and
after rosenbaum is shot you can see
richard mcginnis take off his shirt and
try and provide some sort of medical
care for rosenbaum and so the prosecutor
tries to ask richard mcginnis so he was
falling over rosenbaum when he was shot
right like he just he tripped and then
he was wrongfully shot by rittenhouse
and he was shot for for no reason
because he was just falling over and
then rittenhouse wanted to kill him so
he killed him so it's not self-defense
and richard mcguinness is like well no
actually let me explain
i kind of caught up to them
i was running a bit faster and so
uh at the time initially i was probably
30 feet back when the first when
everybody first started running but then
by the time i arrived in the lot i was
15 feet
and you continued to be behind mr
rosenbaum at the time that the defendant
shot and killed him correct
i did alter my trajectory a little bit
um when i
saw mr rittenhouse turn around and saw
mr rosenbaum
um plunging for the front portion of the
rifle
lunging for the front portion of the
rifle and the prosecutor tries to push
him and tries to say well was he falling
over and uh and the witness says
no he said f u and reach for the weapon
so yeah not
not great not great bob for the for the
prosecution now the way the media are
trying to portray this is as though it's
just a sort of a conflict of visions the
associated press says jurors heard
starkly different portrayals of kyle
rittenhouse instigator or victim in
opening statements at his trial on
tuesday on charges of shooting three
people on the streets of kenosha during
a turbulent protest against racial
injustice a prosecutor said rittenhouse
set the bloodshed in motion when he
triggered a confrontation with a man
that night and then killed him with a
bullet to the back rittenhouse's
attorney told the jury his client acted
in self-defense after the man tried to
grab rittenhouse's gun and others kicked
the teen in the face and clubbed him in
the head with the skateboard and one of
those stories is true and one of those
stories is not and the prosecution story
is not true and then they called a bunch
of witnesses who ripped apart their own
case this thing never should have been
in front of a jury so in a second we're
going to discuss why it was from in
front of a jury in the first place and
what this says about again institutional
trust in the united states which is now
at all time lows first let's talk about
a simple fact it is never too early to
start gift shopping for the holidays
especially because today you can save
big on a gift they will use every day
raycon wireless earbuds with seamless
bluetooth pairing and a comfortable
noise isolating fit you can start
listening right away and keep listening
for hours the audio quality is amazing
it's comparable to what you get from
other premium brands except raycons
start at half the price the new everyday
earbuds they come with three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds it's best with just
the right amount of bass they've got
pure mode for podcast they've got
balance mode for rock they've got bass
mode for hip-hop so you can really rev
up the bass raycons offer eight hours of
play time 32 hour battery life there's
also a built-in mic you can take calls
on your earbuds at the press of a button
so this holiday season get them
something they can use for calls or
music for work or play at home or on the
go or pick up a pair yourself you're
going to be using them every day the way
that i do go to byracon.com today unlock
exclusive deals up to 20 off your recon
order hurry this offer is available for
a limited time only you don't want to
miss it that's buy recon dot com slash
ben i'll mock up to twenty percent off
your records that's by raycon dot com
slash ben alrighty so given the fact
that the prosecution case is just a
complete crap show here why exactly was
it brought in the first place and the
answer is because we live in a society
where the media will not allow a case
not to be brought so long as the
purported
victimizer is of the wrong political
persuasion okay there is no way that if
this were a left-wing person who had
shot a couple of proud boys in the
streets and the video were available
like this that this prosecution has ever
brought it is just too weak a case
politics unfortunately is now telescoped
into individual cases of justice
we're no longer a country where
individual cases are seen for what they
are judged on their fact patterns judged
on their merits instead the outside
politics of the players are telescoped
into the proceedings
and that is exactly the wrong way to do
this right due process of law requires
precisely the opposite we saw this a lot
with the derek chauvin trial in
minnesota regardless of what you think
of derek schoen's activities that day
and now the man has been convicted of
murder and regardless of what you think
of the activities there is still no
evidence in the derek shoving case that
anything he did was motivated by racism
it didn't matter it turned into a giant
national referendum on whether police
across the country were racist despite
the fact there was no evidence that
chovan himself was racist or had done
anything racist as opposed to just
egregiously wrong in the confrontation
with george floyd
and everything is used as a stand-in for
politics these days and the written
house trial is just a perfect example of
that because again the prosecution has
so little a case that they are calling
witnesses who are rebutting the
prosecution case
and they can't stop it if somehow
rittenhouse is convicted here on the
basis of the evidence that's being
presented you can only chalk that up to
politics because there's literally no
way to watch the testimony that's being
given and not see that that's a
self-defense case
well this goes to a broader issue in the
american public mind and that is
institutional trust so another
major story that is that is undermining
institutional trust these days is the
case of igor d'anchenko
so now according to the washington post
an analyst who is a primary source for a
2016 dossier of allegations against
donald trump has been arrested on
charges that he repeatedly lied to the
fbi about where and how he got his
information officials said on thursday
igor danchenko's role in providing
information to british ex-spy
christopher steele who compiled the
accusations about trump in a series of
reports has long been a subject of
scrutiny from internal department of
justice investigators and special
counsel john durham according to people
familiar with the investigations steele
presented that dossier to the fbi it was
part of the basis for secret
surveillance court orders targeting
former trump adviser carter page as the
fbi investigated possible ties between
the 2016 trump presidential campaign in
russia remember the steele dossier was
used as the basis so you target carter
page you remember that in january of
2017 before trump's inauguration or
right after trump's inauguration james
comey approached donald trump and told
him about the steele dossier and that
mere telling him about the steele
dossier was used as the predicate for
buzzfeed then breaking the dossier wide
on its website without vetting any of
the details and this became the basis of
the trump-russia investigation right
trump had deep ties to russia and for
four long years all we heard was that
trump was a russian plant the steele
dossier was still being trotted out as
possibly true as late as like a few
weeks ago abc news's george
stephanopoulos stat sat down with
christopher steele and still was
maintaining that much of the data in
there was still probably true well it
turns out that since 2017 like since the
beginning
of this saga since the early days of
2017 the fbi knew that the key source
for the steele dossier was lying to them
and they know that in 2018 and not 2019
in 2017 no prosecution no attempts to to
quash the st no public statement about
why the seal dossier was a load of crap
none of that
they just kept investigating right the
mueller investigation just kept going
a 2019 report by the justice department
inspector general found major problems
with the accuracy of dan chenko's
information but the 39-page indictment
unveiled on thursday paints a more
detailed picture of claims that were
allegedly built on exaggerations rumors
and outright laws the indictment is
likely to buffer its republican charges
that democrats and fbi agents
intentionally or accidentally turned
cheap partisan smears into a high-stakes
national security investigation of a
sitting president doesn't just buttress
it it proves it
if the democrats wandered a bunch of
dirty probably russian-provided
misinformation through the fbi and then
into the media and then back into law
enforcement hands where it was used as
the basis for large swaths of mueller
investigation
the indictments suggests ann chankl may
have lied to christopher steele and
others about where he was getting his
information some of the material came
from a democratic party operative with
long-standing ties to democratic
presidential nominee hillary clinton
according to the charges rather than
even a well-connected russian with
insight into the kremlin so it turns out
that some of the information wasn't even
coming from russia it was coming from
inside the house from somebody who's
just working with hillary clinton
the washington post admits the
allegations cast new uncertainty on some
past reporting on the dossier by news
organizations including the washington
post
well it's too late everybody won their
pulitzers and donald trump is no longer
president so victory achieved gang
zanchenko appeared briefly thursday in
federal court in alexandria virginia
where his lawyer tried to enter a plea
of not guilty on his behalf for five
counts of making false statements the
judge didn't accept the plea because the
hearing was not an arraignment and
zenchenko was released
so andy mccarthy has a has a good piece
over at new york post about all of this
titled arrest illustrates how the steele
dossier was a political dirty trick
orchestrated by hillary clinton we'll
get to that in just one moment first
right now it's hard to find great
employees to fill your jobs there's just
too many open jobs and not enough people
who are coming back into the workforce
there's a good economic report out today
shows that we added half a million jobs
last month which is indeed excellent
news but
there's still a ton of people out of the
workforce which means that if you're
finding trying to find the best employee
you really need to search with the best
available tool and that of course is zip
recruiter ziprecruiter has an invite to
apply feature it gives you the hiring
manager the power to pick your favorites
from top candidates and right now you
can try that tool for free at
ziprecruiter.com dailywire how does
invite to apply work well when you post
a job on ziprecruiter they send you the
most qualified people for your job then
you can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job lauren webb svp of talent
acquisition for mendula health raves
about zip recruiters invite to apply she
says i love that feature because we have
a much higher follow-through rate if i
invite candidates it's easy for me it's
easy for them in fact according to zip
recruiter internal data jobs where
employers use zip recruiters invite to
apply get on average two and a half
times more candidates which helps make
for a faster hiring process you can see
for yourself just go to this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e to try zip recruiter
for free that is ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zippercrew is indeed the
smartest way to hire already so andy
mccarthy who's been all over this since
the very beginning for national review
now he has a piece in the washington
post about the prosecution of denchenko
he says denchenko has been charged with
five counts of line to the fbi in
interviews during 2017. as the bureau
struggled in futility to verify
outlandish allegations that donald trump
and his campaign were clandestine agents
of the kremlin
those allegations were compiled in the
so-called steele dossier which the fbi
relied on in obtaining surveillance
warrants from a secret federal court the
dossier was generated by the clinton
campaign its principal author was former
british spy christopher steele steele's
main source was danchenko a russian
native based in the united states who
worked at the brookings institute a
washington think tank who's former
president strobe talbot is a college
friend of bill clinton's who worked in
the clinton state department at
brookings danchenko worked with fiona
hill later a member of trump's national
security council and a key witness in
the first trump impeachment over the
unrelated ukraine controversy it was
through hill that zanchenko became
acquainted with steele who ran a
london-based intelligence firm
durham's indictment alleges that
denchenko lied about two major points
first he fabricated the claim that the
president of the russian-american
chamber of commerce informed him that
during the 2016 presidential campaign
trump was involved in a well-developed
conspiracy of cooperation with putin in
reality that conversation never happened
the chamber president is not identified
by name in the indictment after the
steele dossier became public however
there was intense speculation that the
chamber's founder sergey milian was a
steel dossier source
as i recounted my book on russiagate
says andy mccarthy million denied being
a source trashed the dossier as fake
news created by sick mind zanchenko is
also alleged to have concealed that one
of his sources for the information he
was giving to steal was a longtime time
party operative who was close to the
clintons having worked on both of bill
clinton's successful presidential
campaigns and hillary clinton's 2008
presidential campaign that source was
revealed on thursday to be chuck dolan a
public relations executive who had
russian contacts referred to as pr
executive one in the indictment
the fbi interviewed denchenko because it
was desperately trying to corroborate
the steele dossier claims one question
jerome must be pressing is what took the
bureau so long the obama doj brought the
fbi's sworn claims to the secret federal
foreign intelligence surveillance court
in october 2016.
the fbi is supposed to verify the
allegations before going to court but it
didn't interview d'anchenko who was the
main source until january 2017.
it was already obtaining its second 90
day spy warrants on carter page by that
point
it appears that durham theorizes the
trump-russia collusion narrative was a
political attack manufactured by the
clinton campaign relying on zanchenko
steele compiled the reports for glenn
simpson co-founder of an intelligence
firm fusion gps which specializes in
digging up political dirt fusion gps was
retained by perkins coy the clinton
campaign's law firm
in september durham indicted former
perkins quite michael sussman for making
a false statement to the fbi while
peddling trump-russia allegations the
bureau eventually found to be
unsubstantiated
durham
his charging instruments suggest the
clinton campaign used its agents to
peddle the trump-russia rumors to the
government and the media and used the
fact trump was being investigated as
part of the campaign messaging so in
other words if you are talking about
russian interference in the election
it's really democratic interference in
the election by suggesting that a chief
issue in the election is whether trump
was a russian cat's paw which as you'll
recall was trotted out by the clinton
team throughout the election cycle
it turns out that the russian probe very
likely was just a piece of fbi
manipulation by the democratic party and
then the fbi had to cover its own ass
and so refused to actually investigate
all of the people thoroughly who had
given it the information in the first
place until now
it's unbelievable eli lake writes for
bloomberg
it's been clear for two years that
steele dossier is garbage that's mainly
thanks to the work of justice department
inspector general michael horowitz who
released a report in 2019 skewering the
fbi
durham's investigation has taken a
different approach his last two
indictments suggest the fbi was not a
villain but a victim conned by
democratic operatives to pursue bogus
investigations into the trump campaign
danchenko is charged with hiding his
relationship to a prominent democrat in
interviews with the fbi about the
dossier of course that is charles dolan
as we were discussing
the real victim of these democratic
party deceptions was not the fbi however
says eli lake but the democrat but the
american public that's why durham's
investigation now in its third year
remains not only relevant but vital it
is an incredible thing
so what we have here if we if we've got
this right what we have here is that the
steele dossier which was used as the
basis for the fbi opening and
investigation
into donald trump's campaign which ended
up splashed across the front pages of
every major newspaper in 2016 and then
after the election ended up being the
basis of the mueller investigation
which dogged trump for four years
and in frustration at which trump
started making bizarre phone calls and
getting himself in all sorts of legal
hot water it turns out that all of that
was because the media and the fbi
decided to work along with the democrats
in order to take trump down
right that's all that that we're seeing
here
and it took years
for any of these prosecutions to take
place the fbi it's amazing the fbi knew
denchenko was lying in 2017 in 2017. the
calendar now says according to my
calculations that it is 2021 what was
the fbi doing all of this time
institutional trust with the fbi has
been broken for quite a while it should
be broken even further
these institutions
they are motivated by politics
politics have infused them when donald
trump talked about the so-called deep
state people took that to mean that
there was an active conspiracy of people
working inside these departments
sometimes that that may be true right
there are a lot of these people who are
working together obviously if you're
looking at for example peter strzok and
and lisa page if you're looking at that
coupling right those people clearly had
a similar priorities but
in reality all this means that there is
a feedback loop of people who share the
same political echo chamber and you can
apparently retail any piece of garbage
to the fbi
and so long as it is coming from a
democratic source they won't even check
into the sources of the original dossier
they won't even check into it and then
they will launder it this is what james
comey did they will launder it through
the press to the public
and help to
destroy the presidency of a sitting
president of the united states
that is an amazing amazing thing listen
i was loathe to believe a lot of the
early charges there are some people who
are on this way earlier now as that is
for damn sure
that's because i have a certain level of
baseline american trust in these
institutions
that trust has been deeply shaken it
hasn't been shaken for you it's because
you're not watching this closely enough
alrighty coming up we're gonna get to
joe biden's vaccine mandate again these
institutions lose trust so what do they
do they decide to double down and try to
control every area of your life we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
i'll be honest with you at the end of a
long day i am ready to sleep i'm ready
to go down and and the reality is that
if you've got a bad mattress
it makes it tough you don't think about
your mattress all that often because
it's just whatever is on your bed but
you need a mattress that is made for you
this is where helix sleep comes in helix
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences so the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes directly to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
they've got a 10-year warranty you'll
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix has financing options as well so
you can go check them out go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life there's a reason
my wife and i chose helix sleep helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixsleep.comtelixsleep.com alrighty so
meanwhile the biden administration never
at a loss for authoritarian crackdowns
is released they've released as we
mentioned yesterday at length is osha
vaccine mandate
it kicks into place on january 4th
formally there's some speculation that
the reason the bite administration is
doing this is because they don't want it
legally challenged we at the daily wire
have said we will not comply with this
we are not going to force our employees
to get vaccinated this is so
anti-science it is stupid all the way
through if you are vaccinated you are
good to go if you are unvaccinated you
have chosen to be that way and now by
the way
visor is about to come on market with a
pill that after cover diagnosis lowers
your rate of death and hospitalization
by 90 percent
so if we weren't already done then we
are done now
we have been done for months by the way
and if you're a southern state you know
this if you're in an uptight northern
state a northeastern state where they're
still suggesting that you can be
quadruple vast and still be subject to
the predations of covid19 even if you're
not immunocompromised then it's still
going on for you if you're down here in
florida it's pretty much done and it's
been done for quite a while because
we're not crazy down here
okay well the bite administration is
crazy and now they're saying that every
employer of more than 100 people in the
united states
must force their employees to vax or
test weekly and wear a mask
indefinitely
presumably forever and if you refuse to
do this
an unwillful violation costs you 14
grand a willful violation you just say
no i'm not doing that
it's not my business whether my
employees are vast at this point because
everybody's had the opportunity to get
vast if you say that they will they will
send an osha agent to your place of work
and then they will attempt to find you
up up to 140
per violation
they're aiming at small business they're
attempting to bankrupt companies they
don't like and by the way i promise you
that because we are filing a lawsuit
first day that this thing goes formally
into effect in january there will be an
osha inspector door i'm sure that is the
case
again one of the reasons that they're
delaying it is because what they're
hoping is that
if we file a lawsuit a court will say
it's not ripe because there's been no
harm yet
and there's not the case hasn't actually
you can't adjudicate it yet because
there's been no harm we filed for a
preliminary injunction against this many
states are doing the same
hey we need your help with that by the
way head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply to
subscribe that does help us out because
us fighting on behalf of our employees
and getting this law struck down on
behalf of all americans this regulation
that is unconstitutional and by the way
illegal
on behalf of all americans that's in all
of our interests you can help us out by
subscribing we really appreciate it we
need your help with that but
the goal of the divine administration i
don't even think it's for this thing to
take effect i think this is all bullcrap
i think that their goal here is
essentially to pretend that they've done
all they can do get this thing struck
down and then move on with their lives
sort of like their their cdc eviction
moratorium you remember that joe biden
said he didn't have the constitutional
power to issue a further eviction
moratorium because the supreme court
said he didn't and then he did it anyway
and the reason he did it knowing the
supreme court was going to stay that
particular order is because he wanted to
be able to say to his people i did all i
could i i did i i did all i could
that's what that's what he wanted to say
well i feel like this is very much the
same thing see joe biden has put himself
in a box the box is he said he could end
covet he cannot uncover it the only
thing that joe biden could do is leave
us alone but he doesn't want to leave us
alone because he requires covet in order
to ram through these giant spending
bills
in order to maintain control and so now
he's stuck between a rock and a hard
place the longer kovit goes on the worse
it is for the economy
the more these crackdowns go on the
worse it is for the economy and as long
as people are dying covet is not over
from the perspective of democrats so
long as infections are happening even if
they're happening because you chose not
to get vaccinated democrats can't just
say well you know you made your decision
and now it's on you instead they have to
say no no we said we were going to fix
it
okay so joe biden is kind of stuck what
that means is he needs someone else to
blame so he'll he's going to put this
regulation out there we're going to get
it struck down i have very little fear
about that really
and when that happens he's going to
throw up his hands and he's going to say
we did the best that we could
and by the way it's not they're all
hypocrites anyway they they really are i
mean the number of democrats who are
vaccinated but unmasking in public
places when they've been told by the cdc
not to it's astonishing right the rules
don't apply to the special people
i mean rachelle wolensky the head of the
cdc was asked yesterday how many cdc's
employees employees at the cdc were
vaccinated and said she had no idea
what percent of cdc
employees
are vaccinated
we're actively encouraging vaccination
in all of our employees and doing a lot
of education and outreach in order to
get our agency fully vaccinated and the
but the percent
i i don't have that for you today
um so
yeah of course she doesn't have that by
the way i i've noticed that the osha
backs requirements
and the the federal government isn't
trying to attach for example strings to
federal aid so if you are a person who
receives food stamps or welfare via the
federal government i'm noticing that
they're not forcing you to act
interesting how that works only
employers they're trying to turn
employers into
essentially the policemen of the state
which is a complete violation of both
private property and state sovereignty
because this is not a federal issue this
is a state issue
there's nothing in the interstate
commerce clause that gives osha the
power to override the basic health
powers of these states
the the ocean osha come on
there's nothing in the in the osha
regulations that says that they can
regulate literally until the end of time
how you do your work at your business
based on a virus that is not going to
kill you if you are vaccinated by all
statistics
hey and and by the way again everyone's
had the opportunity to get vaccinated
joe biden used to acknowledge he didn't
have the power to do this now he just
does it because he's an authoritarian
according to the wall street journal
employers have until january 4 2020 to
ensure their employees are vaccinated
after that date employers have to verify
that unvaccinated employees test
negative for coven 19 at least once a
week
employers need to show they are fully
vaccinated meaning they either receive
two doses of pfizer or moderna or one
johnson and johnson shot acceptable
documents include a record of
immunization from a health provider or
pharmacy a copy of a covet-19
vaccination card medical records etc etc
the agency plans to inspect some
workplaces a former osha official said
the agency will likely not rely
primarily on in-person inspections but
on company record-keeping and worker
reports of potential violations
businesses that don't comply can face
fines as we say of up to fourteen
thousand dollars and that is if there's
a mistake if you are found to be
unwilling it can be up to 140 000
what will happen to unvaccinated workers
who object to getting vaccinated or
tested it's possible employers would
fire them some workers may choose to
quit
about 40 percent of workers who are
unvaccinated say they will leave their
jobs
rather than do this sort of stuff
okay so
the the entire osha rule here is being
promulgated in idiotic fashion it is not
designed to be upheld but it's going to
have some pretty significant downstream
effects this is why i don't think that
it's actually ever going to be
implemented i think what it's going to
be done what's going to happen here is
that it's going to be used as an excuse
by big businesses to say that they have
to do it
and then biden is just going to lose his
court case and that's going to be the
end of it because here's the problem for
democrats if this thing actually goes
into effect it's going to absolutely
the economy and it's going to be
horrible for the economy
for example truckers are not exempted
from this
if truckers are not exempted from these
regulations if you lose 20 percent of
truckers they got supply chain problems
right now just wait
the white house deputy press secretary
karine jean-pierre she says don't worry
the vax mandate isn't going to affect
the supply chain yeah you're just
forcing people to fire their employees
that's not going to affect the supply
chain at all if you're asking like if we
think the the rules impact supply chain
the answer is no we don't think that it
will uh first of all vaccine
requirements work we we have talked
about that we've given examples like
early adopters have seen strong
compliance 99
at united airlines 99 at houston
methodist 99.5
at rutgers university
recently tyson's food announced that 96
percent of its workers got vaccinated
and have ahead of its deadline so the
emergency temporary standard is an even
playing field across all employers with
hundred or more workers
okay one of the reasons by the way these
percentages are so high is because when
you fire everyone or force them to quit
if they're not vaccinated your
percentages go up amazing how that works
when somebody's no longer an employee
they don't get counted in your
percentage
governors or attorneys general for more
than a dozen states have begun filing
legal challenges already this includes
the iowa governor who had immediate
legal action on thursday
christie noam in south dakota she says
that they're joining a lawsuit as well
today i'm announcing to you that we are
joining several other states
in filing litigation against this
unconstitutional mandate we will be
taking actions to ensure that the
federal government remembers that the
constitution does not give them the
authority to take this type of action
and that people have freedoms and they
have personal responsibility over their
health and that here in south dakota
that will be protected and defended okay
now here's the thing this is all going
to kick in in january can we now have
this pfizer pill which it's apparently
just an oral pill you take after you get
diagnosed and it takes your
hospitalization and death rate down 90
it was already down 90 if you took the
vaccine so if you do that and then you
get a breakthrough and then you take the
pill then basically you're immortal i
think is the way that the math works
there
and even if you don't take the vaccine
we now have a therapeutic that is
effectively as effective as the vaccine
because the vaccines are about 90
effective against hospitalization and
death pfizer says you can now take a
pill and that is just as effective as a
vaccine in terms of preventing
hospitalization and death so what in the
world are they doing here
again it is not about stopping the
pandemic it is simply about control it's
simply about control and and the
backlash is coming man the backlash is
absolutely coming for the democrats it's
going to come hard we'll get to that in
just one moment because it's already
begun first let's talk about a very
different kind of sponsor the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast you really
should take a listen to i know every day
somebody tells you you have to listen to
some podcast or other and you say yeah
sure i'll get to it then you never do
well don't let that happen with jordan's
show apple named it one of its best of
2018 it's aimed at making you a better
informed more critical thinker so you
can get a sense of how the world
actually works
and come to your own conclusions about
what's happening even inside your own
brain each episode is a conversation
with a different fascinating guest when
i say there's something for everyone
here i mean that one episode for example
jordan talks to a hostage negotiator
from the fbi who offers techniques on
how to get people to like and trust you
he's had conversations with people like
kobe bryant right i mean like it's just
interesting stuff even if you don't
always agree with jordan i don't always
agree with jordan i'm not sure jordan
always agrees with jordan what he says
on his show is really really interesting
and he talks with a bunch of people
you'll learn from we heard daily wire
enjoy the show you should check it out
too jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b as in boy inis and nancy
g-e-r on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts go check
it out right now alrighty it is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily ware member today
it's sarah o'connor on twitter who took
trick trick-or-treating to the next
level in the picture sarah and her
fellow are both clutching the world's
greatest tumblr while absolutely killing
the costume game the caption reads we
are celebrating all hallows eve by
dressing up as ben shapiro and his wife
was a doctor folks while drinking from
the elite beverage vessel the leftist
tears tumbler thanks daily wire for
fighting the culture war keep fighting
the good fight we stand with you
that's an excellent costume a very
handsome man a very beautiful woman yeah
i mean like what they're modeling on
thanks for the pick and encouragement
and for being a daily wire member as you
may or may not be aware the daily wire
filed a lawsuit against the federal
government yesterday well because this
is an authoritarian anti-american move
right we have to stop it
the bite administration now ordering
that any employer with over 100
employees has to require employees to be
vast against copa 19 or submit to
regular testing our lawsuit was filed by
dylan law group inc and alliance
defending freedom in the u.s court of
appeals for the sixth circuit the
lawsuit alleges that the biden
administration lacks the constitutional
and statutory authority to issue the
employer mandate and that the mandate
fails to meet the requirements for
issuing a rule taking effect immediately
without the normal process of
considering public comments the
mandate's unconstitutional we're not
standing for it here at daily wire our
employees and yours by the way deserve
to keep their medical histories private
have autonomy over their bodies and
honor any of their religious beliefs
i'm pro-vaxx this isn't about that we
stand with our employees rights as we do
with the rights of every single american
the bite administration has warned that
any companies that don't comply with
this federal overreach could be fined as
much as 136 thousand dollars per
violation so we need your help if you're
not a member yet please consider joining
us today head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code do not comply at
checkout you'll receive 25 off your
membership you'll be fighting the
unconstitutional mandate with us we
appreciate your help we won't comply you
shouldn't either you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
the blowback to democrats command and
control beliefs about the united states
that blowback is strong and it is it
already has teeth and the bite
administration knows it and they are
flailing around over it so honestly the
best story of election night was not
even what happened in virginia it was
the fact that a truck driver defeated
the new jersey state senate leader like
that is hysterical it was a truck driver
named ed durr
he spent i kid you not
about 153 dollars on his campaign
153 on his campaign
66 dollars and 64 cents of that went to
dunkin donuts
that's a campaign my friends yes 153
bucks spent on the campaign
66 bucks two dunkin donuts and he
defeated one of the most powerful people
in new jersey
the state senate president
stephen sweeney
he beat him by about 2 000 votes
and so it turns out that the reason that
the guy ran for office in the first
place as he was denial he was denied a
concealed carry permit in a may carry
jurisdiction meaning that if the
government allows you you may carry and
then who's denied a permit which is it's
perverse i mean i lived in a may carry
jurisdiction in in los angeles and
basically unless you knew somebody you
weren't getting a concealed carry permit
so it's a ridiculous law new jersey has
those kind of laws he got rejected so he
ran for office and uh and here is what
he said about what he plans to do
ed what's the first thing you're gonna
do when you get to the capitol in
trenton
uh i really don't know that's that's the
key factor i don't know what i don't
know so i will learn what i need to know
and i'm going to
guarantee you one thing
i will be the voice and people will hear
me because if there's one thing people
will learn about me i got a big mouth
and i don't shut up when i want to be
heard i'm going to be heard okay so
honestly i wish more of our legislators
had this feeling what's the first thing
you're gonna do i have no idea because i
don't know what is going to confront me
when i get to this place like it's not
bad that regular people are part of our
legislature
in fact i think that most of the experts
in our legislature suck at their jobs
okay so meanwhile the democrats who just
took a shellacking earlier this week
just a brutal shellacking everybody
knows that leading up to 2022 their
prospects are really really poor so what
are they doing they're doubling down on
the idea that all republicans are racist
we got this
it's sort of a microcosm of what
happened right after trump won so right
after trump won there was a brief moment
in time where democrats in the media
were like who are these trump voters
maybe we should go and talk to them and
then after about 32 seconds they said oh
they're a bunch of racists we don't need
to talk to them it's about russia and
racism of course well they just skipped
right over that 32 seconds of
self-reflection over at the white house
and then went right to yeah everybody's
a racist it's because the republicans
are racist so here is uh karen
jean-pierre talking about corinne
jean-pierre the deputy white house press
secretary talking about how republicans
only won in virginia because they lied
about critical race theory good luck
with this one
republicans are lying they're not being
honest they're not being truthful about
where we stand and they're and they're
cynically trying to use our kids as a
political football they're talking about
our kids when it's when it's election
season but they won't vote for for them
when it matters you know republicans did
not vote for the american rescue plan
the american rescue plan in that plan it
had funding to make sure that schools
were open to make sure that our okay
this is a joke this is a joke
it's ridiculous one of my favorite
things democrats are saying right now
it's actually a headline over at the
huffington post right now and i want to
read it verbatim because it really
speaks to what democrats believe about
how politics are supposed to work quote
republicans want parents to be angry
democrats are trying to give them money
that's what democrats think about
politics that all parents want is just
to be handed money by the government
that's all they want they don't want
control over their kids lives they don't
want control over their kids education
they just want to sit down and shut up
and paid off good luck with that message
it turns out that most parents are
concerned mainly with raising their
children
and if there are strings attached to the
cache or we're supposed to sit by and
let crappy school boards decide what our
kids learn in schools about racial
essentialism the answer is no so
democrats instead of saying maybe we
should move away from this critical race
theory nonsense instead they're doubling
down they're saying they're lying about
critical race theory it doesn't exist
it's a bugaboo simultaneously they're
saying it's super important and your
kids have to be taught it you can see
this conflict between for example
stephen colbert and michael eric dyson
so here was stephen colbert last night
mimicking the white house saying that
crt doesn't exist it's a figment of your
imagination
claims about what's being taught in
history classes have become the latest
racist dog whistle for instance on
monday young can made this promise
let me be clear on day one we will not
have political agendas in the classroom
and i will ban critical race theory
here's the thing critical race theory is
not taught at the k-12 level
in virginia
wow that was fast promises made promises
kept it doesn't exist okay obviously
this is a semantic game that people on
the left like to play so what they do is
they say critical race theory really it
doesn't exist critical race theory it's
just that when you dumb it down and you
turn it into ibramex candy racial
essentialism about how
privilege exists in all the institutions
of american life and white kids should
know that they benefit from that
privilege and black kids are inherently
victims that does make it into the
classroom it makes it into the classroom
all the time so they'll simultaneously
say crt doesn't exist and then they will
say that crt is deeply vital to teach to
kids so here is michael eric dyson
yesterday saying we have to make kids
uncomfortable we must make kids
uncomfortable
we got to face some uncomfortable truths
and the white comfort cannot be the
predicate for making sure that race is
not enough as a strategy that shouldn't
be used discomfort is a critical tool to
make people learn when i go to class i'm
talking about my white students my black
students my latino students my asian
students across the board i am trying to
make you uncomfortable enough with the
ignorance that you've inherited so that
you can begin to engage in some serious
thinking about the way the world works
we have to make kids uncomfortable and
what he means by that michael eric dyson
is pretty clear because michael eric
dyson is a proponent of amber max
kennedy's style
which is an offshoot of critical race
theory i mean this is the same guy who's
telling you that he wants to teach her
kids is also saying that the brand new
black lieutenant governor of the state
of virginia is actually secretly white
she's secretly white
so he wants to teach racial essentialism
to your kids that's who this is this is
the person saying that he wants to teach
your kids to feel uncomfortable what
kind of stuff do you think he's teaching
why don't we ask him here's michael eric
dyson
the problem is here they want they want
white supremacy by ventriloquist effect
there is a black mouth moving but a
white idea through the running on the
runway of the tongue of a figure who
justifies and legitimates of the white
supremacist practices we know that we
can internalize in our own minds in our
own subconscious and our own bodies the
very principles that are undoing us so
to have a black face uh speaking in
behalf of a white supremacist legacy is
nothing new
don't worry they're not teaching
critical race theory they just have to
make your kids uncomfortable also
critical race theory doesn't exist and
if you oppose it
too bad we want to give you money and
republicans are bad
good job guys this it's gonna be a
winning message i can see how this is
gonna work out real well for you the
other winning message democrats are
pushing of course is what if we spend
more money now there are a few problems
with this number one americans are not
clamoring for more government spending
at this point bill back better is not
popular even the bipartisan
infrastructure plan it might be sort of
like
okay but it's not blowing the doors off
nobody's clamoring for the bipartisan
infrastructure plan to pass at this
point cnn did a report but the
disconnect is that if you complain about
inflation
then this means that you are out of
touch with the people so this is kind of
an incredible story so yesterday
brianna keeler over at cnn she did a
report about a family okay this family
is a family of 11. they have nine kids
they're feeding nine kids seven of those
kids are adopted or fostered
okay so honestly these people sound like
saints i mean to adopt or foster seven
kids and you have two of your own
pretty incredible behavior okay so
brianna keller keeler does a report on
them and she talks about how inflation
is really taking a trunk out of their
pocketbook here's what the report said
we have two biological kids and then my
wife and i have a big heart for adoption
so we adopted a sibling group of two
then three then one and then we have a
a kid living with us right now who's uh
come in a foster situation it feels like
money isn't going as far as it used to
okay
let's see what we can do
i think probably in june it was about a
dollar was worth a dollar so now that
dollar is worth about 70 cents all right
now we're moving on to dairy which is
right there
we started seeing everything going up
grocery prices went up gallon of milk
was 1.99 now it's 279. well when you buy
12 gallons a week times four weeks you
know you're that's a lot of money
okay and what did this prompt did this
problem to anybody on the left side of
the blue checks on twitter to say
actually that that sounds pretty
damaging right i mean she's right
no instead
you got jemele bowie a man who's in
touch with the people
he tweeted out i'm sorry 12 gallons of
milk
well yes i mean there are 11 people in
the house including nine kids many of
whom apparently are teenagers
he says like if every member of a family
of six had one eight ounce glass of milk
for every meal on every day of the week
you'd still only need about eight
gallons of milk a week
they have 12 people in the house it's
fair enough even then this is an
exceptional family not sure they should
be used as emblematic
well done there jamel bowie just
massive cell phone right there
and jonathan chait does the same thing
blue check 12 gallons of milk a week may
sound like a lot but they've actually
had to cut out their milk baths on
alternate days
they're not taking milk baths like i i
love this so just
just sneer at people who are hurting
at the at the checkout counter just
sneer at them because who needs 12
gallons of milk a week now again basic
math suggests they need 12 gallons of
milk a week right i have three kids we
certainly go through at least three
gallons of milk a week and these are
little kids
okay so the the notion that a bunch of
teenagers like a family of 11 they're
not going to go through 12 gallons of
milk a week
is crazy but then you got the whole blue
check marks going
milk doesn't even cost 1.99 anywhere
okay well in certain parts of the
country it used to
like it did
but these they are all george remember
they said in 1992 the george h.w bush
didn't know how to use one of those one
of those checkout guns at the at the
checkout counter and they mocked him for
it he didn't know how they worked
and it really wasn't true these people
are that they actually are that
they don't
they're all
the old lady from arrested development
what does a banana cost like seven
dollars like that that's what they are
and then they're telling you how they're
gonna fix the economy
good luck with this guys i mean this is
what you really want to run but
apparently they do
apparently they do apparently they think
more cowbell as always doubling down on
stupid we're gonna talk racism we're
gonna pretend that the american people
don't know what they're talking about we
have to boss them around in every
possible way
our elites are just morons okay speaking
of which i have to bring you this
because it's just astonishing so there's
some tape that has now emerged from a
presentation for microsoft
okay all of your intellectual bettors
all the people who run the world who
design the products that you use who
want to run your political life
these people have been indoctrinated in
woke tropes
and then they're cramming them down on
you and they sound like idiots
they sound like morons
and if i were going to have somebody
babysit my kids it would certainly be
the couple that adopted the nine and
have to buy 12 gallons of milk a week
and not the people who are acting as
project managers for these particular
sections at microsoft and i will show
you why so a couple of clips from this
microsoft session again it shows you who
the elites are in our society they're
completely out of touch with everyday
americans completely out of touch with
everyday americans so here is a
microsoft project manager introducing
herself to all the people who are
interested in learning about what
microsoft is doing their new products
okay here we go
my name is allison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top
okay and uh and it continued along these
lines here are a couple of marketing
managers introducing themselves
hello everyone i'm natalie godilla i'm a
caucasian woman with long blonde hair
and i go by she her i'm a product
marketing lead here at microsoft and
co-host of the podcast security unlocked
with this guy yes that would be me hello
everyone i'm nick fillingham i'm a
caucasian man with glasses and a beard i
go by he him and i'm a security
evangelist here at microsoft i go by he
him
and she her okay so apparently the
reason they were describing their races
is for the blind people really for the
visually impaired in the audience so i
have a question you're literally saying
to the literally colorblind that color
matters
this is your pitch your pitch is that
people who are literally incapable
physically of seeing color
must be told what your race is
why
exactly
unclear also we can't just assume from
your voice whether you're a she her or
he him instead you have to name it
that honestly that wasn't even the worst
part of this that allison wines lady she
actually began her little riff by
explaining that microsoft's headquarters
sat on stolen native american land
i kid you not
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the sukwamish the muckleshoot
the snohomish the tulalip and other
coast salish peoples since time
immemorial
so if microsoft wants to they could just
surrender their headquarters to the
local tribe they could do that they
could just give the building over it's
worth a lot of money and it seems like
they're sitting on stolen land from what
i've been told okay so these woke idiots
are the people who run our society
they're the elites who believe they
should control every institutional area
of american life
and the predictable outcome of this is
that even when the people speak up they
will just ignore them this holds true in
the democratic cause of power so nancy
pelosi right now as we speak is
attempting to ram through a build back
better plan that
they ran out the bill like late last
night it's 2000 pages no one has read
this thing they're trying to run this
out despite the fact that the american
people again are not clamoring for it
and the democrats just took a massive
fist to the jaw electorally speaking
and uh what's her excuse for doing this
her excuses well i haven't seen the
election analysis i i don't know i don't
know
do you think democrats were penalized
for having not gotten these things done
again i haven't seen that
and all of the analysis and i know from
my own experience that uh uh
as i've said to you before the plural of
anecdote is not data let's see what the
data is as it comes out oh she doesn't
know the data i'm pretty sure that uh
she knows the data she just doesn't care
because they she has to ram this through
now the problem for her of course is
that the politics don't actually favor
ramming it through
it looks as though the the democratic
party is split almost revocably at this
point between the joe manchin and
kirsten cinema wing of the party and the
aoc wing of the party now aoc's takeaway
yesterday from the virginia loss by the
way is that they weren't progressive
enough in virginia
which is a hell of a takeaway
considering that the candidate she
endorsed in buffalo india walton was the
only democrat actually on the ballot and
proceeded to lose by 20 points to a
writing candidate so yeah clearly
americans are desperate for more
progressivism but democrats keep hunting
for the votes they keep trying to cram
this thing through what's amazing about
this by the way is that basically it it
is kind of incredible that the
progressives are caving this way truly
so what the progressive plan was was we
are going to hold up infrastructure
until joe manchin and kirsten cinema
sign off on buildback better
joe manchin and kirsten cinema are not
signing on to anything that the house is
going to pass today it's not it's not
happening and they have no interest in
in passing this thing the actual number
on the bill is not 1.85 trillion it is
more like 4 trillion according to
wharton business school
is they're not signing on to it
and the house democrats know this in the
progressive caucus
so they could hold up infrastructure or
they could just vote for infrastructure
and surrender it looks like they're
about to do the latter nancy pelosi for
her part she keeps saying that bill back
better is not going to increase
inflation uh weird because i i think
that it probably is
the other piece was about inflation and
we had the uh expert opinions and in
fact very recent
today from
moody's that
the bill was paid
since it is paid for
it would not increase inflation and in
fact it would add to our economy because
of
child care enabling many more women to
fully participate oh so it's gonna it's
gonna be better it's getting better
again they took they took a hit right to
the draw and they just keep they keep
trucking because they know better than
you they know more than you and that's
all that matters because they are the
specials and you are not one of the
specials they are the specials according
to politico's playbook
democratic leaders are still facing
resistance from centrists who have
raised procedural concerns such as a
lack of cost analysis with the push for
a vote on the sprawling social policy
package this week pelosi circulated a
letter thursday night that included
budgetary details from white house staff
several democrats say they want the
details from congress's independent
scorekeepers not a partisan one
now democrats are going to try and ram
this thing through today
one of the problems of course is that
the caucus goes on vacation next week
members of the caucus are set to embark
on overseas trips ahead of next week's
recess so they're hitting a deadline but
party leaders failed to corral the votes
they needed on thursday so it's going to
be interesting to see how how they
accomplish ramming this thing through if
they can even do it joe manchin for his
part he's like you can pass whatever the
hell you want i didn't say him to vote
for it
people are concerned they're concerned
about inflation they're concerned about
the debt no no we don't talk about it
but they are concerned i can tell you
back home in west virginia gas prices
are enormous people are having a hard
time driving to work and paying 20 to 30
dollars more to fill up they're going to
the grocery stores and getting 30
percent less they're about ready to face
a very bad winter we are we're told at
much higher prices so yes i think we
should be up front honest and
transparent with american people and do
what we can afford to do okay so here's
the problem the biden administration has
every incentive never to be upfront and
transparent with the american people
because if they were they'd have to
acknowledge that they've lied to the
american people since the election
the election was all about joe biden
being moderate he lied he's not a
moderate
and of story so he continues to lie the
lies just come fast and furious
yesterday joe biden ripped peter ducey
over him asking a question about paying
off illegal immigrants to the tune of
450 000 a pop
and now this was a report from the wall
street journal that the doj was going to
sign a settlement with families who had
been separated to pay families each
member of the family had been separated
450 000 so like almost a million bucks
if you're an illegal immigrant dad and
you crossed with your kid and then you
were separated because you illegally
immigrated and under the flores
settlement if we held you we had to
separate your kid from you we're gonna
pay them nearly a million bucks thanks
to the aclu and the biden doj heroes
biden ripping on peter ducey for even
asking the question
as you were leaving for your overseas
trip there were reports that were
surfacing that your administration is
planning to pay
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their families at the border up to
450 000 each possibly a million dollars
per family
do you think that that might incentivize
more people to come over illegally if
you guys keep sending that garbage out
yeah
but it's not true so this is a garbage
report yeah okay so 450 450 000
per person is that what you're saying
that was separated from a family member
at the border under the last
administration that's not going happen
that's not gonna happen um the aclu then
put out a statement said um it's already
happening and then cnn cnn was like uh
yeah that's not true daniel dale making
a rare appearance on cnn these days to
critique a democrat and he he's like the
man on the side of the milk carton that
that family of 11 is buying he just he
completely disappeared from cnn's
airwaves for large swaths of time
remember he used to go out there and
fire hose how much trump was lying and
now only occasionally does he does he
come out and note that joe biden is a
horrible
liar the wall street journal was correct
not reporting garbage when it reported
that the biden administration is in
discussions to settle lawsuits brought
on behalf of families affected by the
family separation policy and the wall
street journal was correct in reporting
that the settlement discussions include
talks of possible financial compensation
in fact white house deputy press
secretary karine jean-pierre said today
at the white house briefing that
president biden is comfortable with
financial compensation as long as it
ends up saving taxpayers money and helps
people turn the page from the horrors of
the trump days okay so uh that means
biden was lying and by the way the white
house acknowledged it like he's so out
of it he's not even a part of his own
administration here's karine jean-pierre
saying this
the president is perfectly comfortable
with the department of justice settling
with the individuals and families who
are currently in litigation with the us
government you know doj can obviously
speak more to that process the president
was what he was reacting to
was the dollar figure that was mentioned
that you mentioned to him yesterday
as press accounts today indicate there's
been press accounts on this doj made
clear to the plaintiffs that the
reported figures are higher than
anywhere that a settlement can land
okay so there is the white house
basically acknowledging that joe biden
is uh is full of it man's not in control
of his own administration but these are
the elites and so they must be in
control of you so man who's not in
control as i've said of zoned bowels is
going to be in control of every aspect
of your life and then you're supposed to
trust the institutions because they've
demonstrated such feelings to principle
over the past several years
yeah the blowback is coming and it's
coming hard alrighty we have reached the
end of today's show but we will be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content first you can't forget to end
your week by checking out the andrew
clavin show cruz shows every friday he's
got an exciting evening planned for you
as always head on over to dailywire.com
at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin